اعلنت ديوان الملكي الهاشمي يوم الاربعاء
السابع عشر من اغسطس في عام 2022 عن خطوبه
الامير الحسين من الانسه رجوى خالد بن
مساعد بن سيف بن عبد العزيز ال سيف فمن هي
هذه السعوديه التي ستصبح اميره في الاردن
هي مهندسه معماريه تبلغ من العمر 29 عاما
ولدت في الرياض وتلقت تعليمها الثانوي في
السعوديه ثم درست الهندسه المعماريه في
جامعه سيراكولوس في نيويورك في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
والدها اصوله من قبيله السبيعي وهو رجل
اعمال ومالك شركه السيف للمقاولات
الهندسيه المحدوده وبعد الزواج ستحصل رجوه
على لقب زوجه ولي العهد الاردني على غرار
صاحب السمو الملكي وبمجرد زواجها رسميا من
ولي العهد ستكون رجوى قادره على تمثيل ولي
العهد في المناسبات مثل حفلات الزفاف
اعضاء العائلات الملكيه
[موسيقى]
الشعب يغني للاظي وحسيني الشعبي
الامير حسين ظلوا العرسان وطنتهم مهيوبه
الله العرسان وطلت
فرحتنا اليوم على القمر مكتوب فرحتنا
اليوم على
[تصفيق]
متابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات